alors michel ce soir tu viens de voir
aussi pour la sortie de son livre
surtout ça ira mieux demain dans steve
tu reviens sur ce que tu as traversé sur
les coulisses de son opération du coeur
des premiers signes d' alerte jusqu'à
ton retour à l'antenne en plus on s'est
vus on avait pris un petit déjeuner
ensemble
michel juste avant pas longtemps avant
j'étais déjà moyens c'est vrai elle n'a
pas senti moins élevés dans des
problèmes respiratoires
c'est vrai je l'aï pas sentie parce
qu'on s'était vu un matin avec michel
est un frein after ensemble et à partir
du 30 août dernier tu vas passer son
jour dans le plus grand secret à
l'hôpital pompidou
le livre commence à la veille de son
opération à coeur ouvert à cause d'une
suite de pépin cardiaque comme tu dis
est très vite dans livre tu évoques
l'injustice d'avoir de tels soucis de
santé
et c'est ce que j'ai pensé tout de suite
tu te jure un michel sans avoir fumé but
en ayant fait du sport et tu te jure
c'est la première chose à laquelle j'ai
pensé
oui mais c'est ce qui m'a sauvé c'est
changerait m'a dit si vous aviez eu 20
kg de plus avait picolé fumée et si vous
aviez une vie un peu compliqué je vous
aurais pas opérer parce qu'ils soient il
restait sur la table d'opération
ces skins en même temps sauver parce que
moi je suis comme je suis un peu la même
vie je me suis dit bon ben voilà
mitchell ouais tu te couches très tôt
huawei non mais c'est vrai michel une
union l'une des repas sains
winder pas celle peu de noël je dormais
quand même nombreux mois il m'arrive la
pl 3 heures du matin il est saoul et là
il regarde les audiences et sa chute et
j'ai voulu écrire ce livre sur tout et
tu l'as vu jeudi dédiée aux chirurgiens
ou ccao grand cardiologue qui en france
qui sont parmi les meilleurs du monde ne
pouvait sans carpentier c'est lui le
vanter le coeur artificiel
à propos aucun pompier c'est c'est car
quart matt le quart matt c'est
carpentier et matra jean luc lagardère
ainsi jean-luc lagardère et matra qui
ont financé le premier coeur artificiel
il faut le dire mais j'ai voulu écrire
ce livre pour rendre hommage aux
infirmes et en personnel soignant et à
l'hôpital public parce que je
connaissais un peu cet univers puisque
je viens du milieu médical par mon père
et mon frère mon jeune frère
mais lorsqu'on est lorsqu'on va à
l'hôpital voir un copain malade je suis
accompagné beaucoup d'amis célèbres
malheureusement dans la dernière ligne
droite mais quand on est soi-même
le patient au goutte à goutte c'est puis
la même chose et donc j'ai vu ce que
c'était que le suspect d'enfermement ce
le silence la morphine les antidouleurs
délais s'il paraît elle y pense c'est
vrai que j'ai voulu que la solide pour
rendre hommage au personnel soignant aux
infirmières qu'on applaudisse et
beaucoup sur les balkans il ya un an et
qu'on a oublié depuis exactement les a
pas oubliés un il faut pas les oublier
surtout alors tu penses que tu as trop
forcé sur ton coeur à cause du vélo
non je crois que c est trop forcé par le
stress vraiment ah ouais ouais pour
déstresser de quoi bein 57 ans de télé
ça fait beaucoup et 53 merz avait sur
les plus durs ouais c'est beaucoup de
stress c'est vrai vraiment et je me suis
mis une grosse grosse pression au cours
des dernières années
en voulant réaliser un challenge dont je
réveille toi aussi d'aller sur scène
maintenant je suis allé sur scène
alalala journée de la retraite depuis
longtemps et ça ça m'a beaucoup stressé
mais je verrai commencé en janvier de
saintes ont dit que c'était un tas
d'immondices bon travées eu des alertes
ou pas avant j'étais un petit peu
essoufflé j'aimerais que trois petits
lisez soufflement sur le vélo j'ai fait
le ventoux trois fois trop tôt j'ai fait
le téléthon en vélo j'avais à 50 balais
520km gelé dans les sous-marins
nucléaires je suis allé sur la calypso
avec cousteau je suis avec besson sous
la banquise
j'ai fait beaucoup beaucoup de conneries
d'un banal et sauter en parachute
j'ai fait beaucoup de choses je les sors
charles de gaulle plusieurs fois parce
que j'aime ça et que seul le sport c'est
ma passion c'était ma vie j'ai faisait 1
coupe du monde mais gégé sans doute
était beaucoup trop impliqué pendant ce
métier trop stressé car c'est
contrairement à ce qu'on pense c'est un
métier de stress un métier d'angoissé en
plus j'ai fait une parano kg parvenir
pendant trois ou quatre ans j'ai
vraiment cru que j'étais trop vieux
qu'il fallait que je parte
donc ça va beaucoup travailler parce que
on a souvent parlé tous les deux je me
disais comment sortir par le haut
comment comment sortir avant conteuse ap
comment partir dignement et pas faire le
fameux combat trop ça c'est le sport tu
feras jamais le combat de trop en fait
je lis ma toute façon le cardio m'ont
dit avec le coeur quand vous avez vous
êtes là pour sentant bon bah magnifique
donc les jeunes attendront encore un
mois il n'y aura sur ces 8 après sur
canal
un certain le patron c'est pas dans
[Rires]
l'hôpital avait pris un pseudo michel tu
t'appelais ça a fait rire un fiacre bio
car je suis arrivé à l'hôpital puis de
pompidou y voit trois mille personnes
800 lits j'ai écouté avec le co vide
avec les portables avec la presse qu'on
valait parker ça je vais pas y couper
puis des noms alors prenez problème ce
dôme et ne pas avoir confiance mais
prenable ce dossier vous dire quel
pseudo
j'ai dit madiot car pourquoi j'ai besoin
d'un verre de cardio anvers joca et ils
prennent j en connais quoi aujourd'hui
c'est la saint fiacre va pour fiacre
d'oka et pendant quatre mois ça va
monsieur duka mais en fait les
infirmières étaient pas tout à fait dupe
parce que quand j'allais au scanner pour
la énième fois
mais l'irm je vois bien que certaines
savez très bien que monsieur diot cas
ressemble à quelqu'un qu'on voit le
dimanche après midi
jusqu'au jour où après avoir perdu 11 kg
j'ai entendu une infirmière dire à
l'autre avant que dalle au scanner
germaine ça grossit la télé j'avais
perdu 11 kg et là j'ai vu qu'elle savait
qui j'étais à la maison et etops et ils
ont ils ont gardé le pseudo jusqu'au
bout ni arrière moment dans le livre on
découvre qu'il ya eu des moments où tu
en es tu à craquer tu as tu le dit est
apte à craquer je ne retrouverai jamais
la télévision je ne retournerai plus
nulle part diminué 1 sortable un
montrable dans les choux en attendant de
sucrer les fraises les docteurs ne me
dise pas oui y croit encore ou font
semblant moi je le sais c'est fini et
oui parce que quand on te dit vous avez
l'infection gravissime l'endocardite
infectieuse de la valve mitrale que la
rater et touché que le rein est touchée
que vous avez un petit début d'avc et
que votre jambe droite va être coupé
dans les quatre heures si on a des
bouges pas parce qu'elle est née creuser
plus un triple pontage tu dis il ya peu
de chances que de que tu reviennes
vivant en tout cas très handicapée et il
ya aucune chance que tu te retrouves
debout devant une caméra ce n'est pas
possible pour moi c'est un
extraterrestre
c'est ce que disent les charges c'est
incroyable johnny tu sais ça que tu dis
tu sais même pas si c'est un miracle oui
je
voilà j'ai cru que c'était terminé et
j'ai pensé j'ai pensé à beaucoup de
choses je regardais évidemment un peu la
télé mais c'est très étrange tout ceux
qui me regardent connaissent ça avec la
morphine et les anti douleurs
on est dans des délires rien chapic j'ai
appelé sur l'écran noir 2008 blanche
mclane oeil à nougaro tiens voilà sur
l'écran je t'ai vu passer j'ai revu mes
est d'aider des souvenirs avec benji
gérer vu passer beaucoup de choses de ma
vie et je me disais après tout je n'ai
pas été élevée dans la tradition
religieuse je suis pas croyant mais
après tout retrouver johnny retrouver
gainsbourg avec sharon stone aznavour
trouver dassin charles aznavour à
coluche le luron mon frère mes parents
je me disais après tout si une vie après
la vie
j'ai une autre vie qui va commencer
michel mois ce qui ce qui est fou et je
pense que tous les téléspectateurs qui
nous regardent ce soir en direct sur ces
8 se disent c'est incroyable michel unis
sur son lit d'hôpital ils se sont il
sent qu'il n'a aucune chance de revenir
la première chose à laquelle il pense et
je ne reviendrai plus à la télé mairie
c'est fou mais oui mais parce que parce
que je suis sûr qu autour de la table
tous et tous tes amis quand ils
reviendront plus tombeur de pas vraiment
si on te dit demain cyril demain c'est
fini
la télé oui pour l'argent ou jusqu'au
michel pense que oui parce qu'il me
connaît mieux que moi
moi je pense que non multiplient un
médecin qui va plus soignée un chanteur
à ses attentes et tu peux pas moi j'ai
vu sourceforge accompagner dans la
dernière heure de sa vie j'en parle
d'ailleurs dans l'est michel delpech ces
risques au diable qui avait qu'il y
avait sous ses draps l'épouvantable
d'avoir un cancer de la gorge pour un
chanteur ouais bon j'ai accompagné
beaucoup d'amis et c'est vrai que moi
mon père qui était un médecin de
campagne comme on n'en fait plus ben à
81 12 ans parce qu'à 80 ans oui il a
fait un accouchement six ou huit jours
avant de nourrir un bon et c'était sa
vie et s'il n'avait pas eu un petit
problème à l'estomac va y seraient ils
auraient exercé son métier consentants
et tous ceux qui visent maintenant c'est
pas vrai c'est pas notre métier est un
métier à part c'est un métier magnifique
extrêmement compliqué surtout si on veut
s'installer dans la durée
mais c'est un métier magnifique regarde
il n'y a pas une journée qui ressemble
bien sûr sa servante de gens regardent
est conférée croisé dans le couloir des
sont extrêmement paisible qui met
s'engueuler avec moi mais c'est sûrement
y en aura d'autres j'ai un autre moment
du niveau type tu dis pendant ces nuits
du début de l'automne 2001 j'ai cessé
d'exister je crois je suis devenu une
vieille plantes malades de forme humaine
sans avenir ni soleil il n'ya plus que
mon coeur qui tape régulier dans ma
poitrine couture et rien d'autre aucun
et l'on sait c'est le capital public en
france à ceci d'extraordinaire
qu'on soit riche et célèbre c'est ça
qu'on soit défavorisé et inconnus on est
soigné la même exactement elle arrive à
être un carte vitale c'est vrai que par
est à 4 vital que tu sois un émir où que
tu sois un sdf et ce à tous ceux qui
m'ont soigné je les ai observés de très
près c'était une aventure un voyage un
ce extraordinaire même si je pensais ne
pas revenir de ce voyage j'ai vu des
gens magnifiques
j'ai vu des infirmières des aides
soignantes de nuit qu'on dévie
incroyable mais juste michel humez
regagner leur vie qui habite à à 2h30 de
paris
on a beau le savoir mais quand est
soignée que tu es quelqu'un qui a un peu
pignon sur rue j'étais persuadé que moi
j'étais persuadé que j'étais inoxydable
un terminator que j'ai que que j'étais
aussi destructives si j'étais persuadé
de sa pourquoi était avec moi il un
quand tu vois deux femmes charmantes qui
ont peu dormi qui ont amené leurs gosses
à l'école quand des problèmes avec leurs
maris de chômage des problèmes
économiques pendant la coulpe en france
cette année épouvantable sur l'économie
que tout était à l'arrêt et qui arrive
avec le sourire ici remonte le moral à
l'est misrata
vous allez vous en sortir vous pour
frais de la télé est l'élément
d'immenses reprend à est étiqueté rien
tu es un pantin étaient disloqués tasse
en temps quand tu te regarde dans la
glace
j'ai mis deux mois avant d'enlever la
buée sur la glace après la douche quand
j'ai vu la tête que j'avais je
ressemblais à raouf ben le messin de
marseille cette société et j'ai dit mais
c'est pas possible j'ai jamais je vais
refaire surface dont elle avait plus de
jambes j'avais plus de plus de plus de
muscle nulle part il ya un moment très
fort dans le livre c'est une
conversation que tu avec l'équipe
médicale
tu dis attendez si ça se passe mal je le
dis en présence du docteur hagège vous
me débrancher
comment ça je vous des branches oui
débrancher mois hors de question que je
puisse me réveiller avec des handicaps
avec une aphasie un tremblement je ne
pourrai plus jamais pratiquer mon métier
alors ce n'est plus la peine vous me
débrancher ce n'est pas légal vous
débranchez plutôt mourir que me
réveiller son pouvoir exercer mon métier
ça c'est un assassinat et fort oui parce
que tous ceux qui ont été opérés qui me
regarde et je leur souhaite vraiment de
garder le moral
c'est là que ça se passe aussi c'est le
protocole il n'y a pas d'opération sans
risque et une opération comme la mienne
a été gigantesque
il fait les conventions genval coface
afrique le portage comme des bouche la
jambe qu'on surveille de début d'année
c'est dans ma vidéo on saura si vous
avez des séquelles uniquement au réveil
on opère un choeur par le cerveau donc
on sera au réveil est donc le protocole
c'est ça le le l'anesthésique 01 10
voilà si ça se passe mal on prévient qui
si ça veut dire quoi
non mais vous savez nous allons prendre
un gros risque avec cette opération il y
avait 50 50
donc qui on prévient mais si vous prenez
ma femme d'abord mais vous débranchez
mais quand ça veut dire vous débranchez
j'ai dit ça devant albert à jet ski le
patron du service de cardiologie de
l'hôpital européen georges-pompidou
cassis élu pour la première fois en
général c'est un tête à tête entend des
anesthésies c'est le malade personnes là
si ça ça j'ai dit vous débranchez si
vous venez pour débrancher parce que
parce que je valais
je peux pas alors je pouvais pas pour
faire mon métier si pour ça que j'en
suis très reconnaissant à la gouvernance
de france télé maudit on t'attend sarti
on t'attend anglais des gentils on
m'attendait
mais si je reviens diminué je vais
revenir j'ai entendu parler de prothèses
puisqu'on devait me couper la jambe au
dessous du genou droit
prothèse je dis bon vin j'irai le voir
syrie avec une prothèse
voilà et puis on fait du tennis et
qu'une prothèse à ces jeux et je fais du
vélo sur une jambe comme un mec qui m'a
doublé un jour dans le ventoux car un
bras et à une jambe a repris le vélo là
non chez moi oui est officiellement non
non bon dit non alors il ya les
cardiologues qui me regardent ils ont
redit dans les cas de l'ong iam monsieur
le professeur jeu il n'a pas repris
est-ce que vous avez des questions à
poser à michel merci d'être là où ses
doigts
moi ce qui me frappe dans le livre c'est
que les médecins vous dise
après l'opération vous avez une chance
sur quatre 25% de chances de mourir ce
qui est énorme d'habitude n'arrivèrent
pas mais ce qui vous a sauvé c'est votre
mental expliquez-nous comment le mental
dans ces cas là peuvent faire que on
survivre c'est quoi c'est l'envié de
vivre alors je parle devant benji qu'il
fasse partie fléchir illégalement et à
d'autres sportifs autour de la table
moi j'ai fait 3 fois les ventes avaient
déjà 50 ans j'ai failli mourir trois
fois de douleur mais je voulais pas
abandonner
j'ai fait le le téléthon 520 km le mont
saint michel paris dans les années 90
pour le téléthon dont 18 heures de nuit
dans la pluie et le vent il faisait 5
degrés j'ai pas vendre ce à dire que mal
le mental je les jeunes est toujours eu
et essayé et on ne peut pas se sortir
d'un drame pareil quel que soit
d'ailleurs l'opération si on n'a pas un
mental trèfle et michel moi je vais dire
est que je pense qu'on peut pas faire ta
carrière à la télé sans mental et on
voit breton les très grands animateurs y
en a 5 6 mentale d'un mental d'acier